>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Our next guests are
co-authors of This is Just a Test.
Madelyn Rosenberg and
Wendy Wan-Long Shang.
When she was in fifth grade, Madelyn
Rosenberg wrote a story entitled,
How the Raccoon Got His Mask.
Is that correct?
Yeah. Her family took this as a
clue that she'd become an author
of children's literature
as an adult.
And she did just that.
Madelyn Rosenberg has written many
books appealing to kids of all ages,
such as How to Behave at a
Tea Party, The Nanny X books.
Her middle grade and young
adult books include The Canary
in a Coal Mine and Dream Boy.
Fans love her for their
humor or fans love her books
for their humor and inventiveness.
When Wendy Wan-Long
Shang was a young girl,
she realized that books gave her the
freedom to "learn about anything,
go anywhere, pretend to be anyone."
It's not surprise that
she became an author.
Her award-winning books include
The Great Wall of Lucy Wu,
and The Way Home Looks Now.
Their newest book, This is
Just a Test, tells the story
of a bicultural young man trying to
make sense of the world around him
in cold war 80's America.
Reviewers and readers alike
give it a big thumbs up.
So be sure to stop by the Politics
and Pros Bookshop to pick up a copy
and then get it signed
between 11 a.m. and noon.
So without further adieu,
let's give a round of applause
and a warm welcome to Madelyn
Rosenberg and Wendy Wan-Long Shang.
[ Applause ]
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Wendy Shang.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg:
I'm Madelyn Rosenberg.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
And as he just said,
we are the authors of
This is Just a Test.
So how many of you have ever
seen two people get into a fight
and wonder should you speak up
or maybe if you just kept quiet,
everything would blow over?
That's pretty much what's going
on with our main character,
David Da-Wei Horowitz who is
half Chinese and half Jewish.
And no one in David's
world is getting along.
His grandmothers don't get along,
and his friends aren't
getting along.
It's the 80's, so really it feels
like the world isn't getting along.
But when David starts
entertaining the idea
that he could leave a friend
out of an important project,
he learns that there are
no shortcuts to peace.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: And
we're going to start by --
I'm just going to read a
little bit from the beginning.
Even though we work together,
we are different heights
so I need a smaller -- so our book
starts out where David's class is
on a school field trip at a farm
in Virginia where almost everything
on the farm is dead
including the poison ivy.
The teachers told a group of
us to sit at the picnic tables
so they could pass around
seeds and dry gourds,
which Mr. McKemmon
actually did grow.
Hector, my best friend,
squirmed between the bench
and the table and ducked underneath.
What are you doing?
I asked. The other kids
were giving Hector a look.
It's shadier down here, Hector said.
One thing I'll say about Hector, he
is not afraid to be unconventional.
It used to be a quality I
admired like when Hector suggested
that we do everything backwards
for a week or when he signed us
up for correspondence classes in
French because he wanted to go
to the Cannes Film Festival one day.
But in junior high,
unconventionality was usually
just another word for dork.
Knock off, I told Hector.
I was pretty sure under
the transitive property
of junior high school social lives
whatever our group was thinking
of Hector, they were going
to start thinking of me.
Hector popped back up.
My little brother does that all
the time, said Kelly Ann Majors.
I happen to know that Kelly
Ann's little brother was eight.
It was one of the facts I
had collected about her.
It was also exactly what I was
afraid someone would think.
Watch this, said Scott Dirsky who
was in a couple of my classes.
Under normal circumstances, I
ignored Scott and his stunts,
but now he was providing a
distraction, the good kind.
I watched him, hoping everyone
else would too as he walked
to the oak tree that had a bunch
of vines attacking the trunk.
It looked like tentacles.
Scott grabbed one to try to
get some climbing leverage,
but the vine was loose, and it fell
out of the tree while
he was holding it.
Terry [inaudible] stood
behind him and said nice try,
let me show you how it's done.
Scott grabbed a different
vine for a better hold.
It was furry.
Even from where we were sitting,
I could tell it was poison ivy.
That's poison ivy, I told Hector.
They shouldn't be touching that.
Hey, Hector shouted.
That's poison ivy!
Says who? Scott didn't
let go of the vine,
but you could see his
grip relax slightly.
Says David, said Hector.
We walked over to the tree.
I don't see any leaves, said Hector.
You can get poison ivy from
the vine, too, I told him.
You know, hairy vine,
no friend of mine?
It still contains [inaudible].
I've never heard that, Scott said.
But he let go of the vine.
He's making it up, said Terry.
He patted the vine which looked
like the tail of a scruffy cat.
This is my pet, Lucky.
He would never hurt me.
Don't you want to meet my pet?
He reached for the closest
girl who shrieked and ran away.
Why would I make it up?
I said. If I were going to make
something up, it would be something
like studying too much for your
bar mitzvah can stunt your growth
or eating only Chinese food
causes premature baldness.
Personally, I would like to spend a
lot less time studying [inaudible]
and more time eating pizza.
And that's sort of how we
begin our story about David.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: So
it's a little strange for us
in anything basically in the
kidlet world that's over ten years.
It's set more than
ten years in the past.
It's considered historical fiction.
But even knowing that, it's a
little devastating to realize
that something set in the 80's
is considered historical fiction,
but when you think about it,
when we start thinking about it,
we realize that there are things
from the 80's that we mention
in the book that would be completely
foreign to young readers today.
So -- and we want to remind
you people when you start --
if you're tempted to start
laughing at some of these things,
one day that maybe 2017 will
seem kind of historical.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: That's right.
If you guys are walking around,
and you've seen people with clothes
where the shoulders are exposed,
I think it's called the
cold shoulder, right?
That's going to be 2017,
and there are 2000 --
there are different
voices, different vocabulary
that people are going to
be using in the future
so that the things we say
now are going to be strange.
And [inaudible] are one of
the things that I think is --
was different when
we were growing up.
And I don't have Diet
Coke in this picture,
but I should because you see
Diet Coke everywhere, right?
That wasn't invented until 1982.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
Wait, hold on.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg:
One microphone.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
Another thing that was
different were video games.
Who here likes to play video games?
Oh yeah. So what do you --
use your thumbs, right, right?
You have a screen, and you
can see lots of cool stuff.
Well, video games looked
a little different,
and we played them a little
differently when we were growing up.
So this is a picture from a game
called -- do you know the name?
Space Invaders.
Good job! And instead of
getting to use your thumbs
and these virtual buttons and
everything, we got to use this.
Look at this.
Look at the range of
motion on this thing.
Yeah. You had those?
So we thought we'd demonstrate
for you what it was
like to play with this.
So Madelyn is going
to be my avatar, okay?
And we can only see
them from the side.
So it'd be like go!
Go! Go! Go!
And maybe jump!
Jump! So you guys have it
much better than we did.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: Also
computers were something
that looked a little bit different.
They were -- not many
of us even had them.
They certainly weren't
something that you carried
around like a purse
or in your purse.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
And in fact,
how many of you use a thumb
drive at school or at work?
Right? So this is actually
the more updated version
of what we had to work with.
Okay? This holds two megabytes.
So if you wanted to have enough
storage to have the same amount
in your 16 gigabyte, do you
know how many you would need?
I can't hear you, what?
They were called floppies,
but they were --
the first ones were really skinny
and you could wave them back
and they would kind of wiggle.
These were like the
more updated versions.
If you wanted to have
the same amount of memory
in a 16 gigabytes thumb drive --
>> Can't hear you.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Oh.
16 gigabytes thumb drive as
you could in one of these,
you would need over 11,000 of these.
And speaking about carrying
things around in a purse,
you guys want to guess
what's in here?
What's in there?
What do you think?
What'd she say?
>> Madelyn Rosenberg:
What'd you say?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
Another one of these.
Yeah, we started carrying
the 11,000 in the purse?
No. This is -- can you get it out?
The Velcro is super strong in here.
That was a cell phone.
That's a cell phone.
Okay, and this is really
-- you have to take it --
wait, you have to take it all the
way out with a very strong pull.
Velcro. Look at this guys.
Do you want to make a phone call?
Here's your antenna.
Dot, dot. Right?
And you ever wonder why
we say hang up the phone?
Right? Because you
hang up the phone.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: And
when you talked into it,
it sounded like this
[crackling sound].
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Okay.
And then speaking of other
expressions, we had expressions
from the 80's, like if you thought
something was totally gross,
you might say gag me
with a spoon or --
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: That did not
get as far as southwest Virginia.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: So what are
some of the -- what do you think --
what are some of the phrases
that you guys have now
that might seem like unusual?
What do you think?
What's that?
[ Inaudible ]
Oh. Or like LOL?
You guys say LOL?
Yeah? Yeah, a lot of those.
They weren't around
when were [inaudible].
There might be something totally
different 30 years from now.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: And then
the things that we wore were a lot
of different -- really
different from they are now.
The clothes were different.
The colors were different.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
The hair was different.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: Our
hair was very different.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: So we
wanted to take a moment to discuss
to you the importance of
shoulder pads in the 80's.
This was considered a
very important accessory.
So let's say you had a
regular day at school.
You might just have a one
shoulder pad situation.
So it makes you look
strong and powerful.
But what if you had a book report?
Well then you'd want definitely a
bigger shoulder pad and if you were
in trouble and you might have
to go visit the principal,
you would definitely want the
biggest shoulder pads you had.
So look at the pictures carefully.
You could see the difference.
So don't I look more
powerful on this side?
It was a little strange.
And how did we listen to music?
Here we go.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: So we used
Walkmans to listen to music,
and we put cassette tapes in the
Walkmans and even though CD's came
out in the 80's, this
was usually the method.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
There we go.
Yeah. They just had -- they had one
minor technical flaw [inaudible]
occasionally went wrong,
and the tape would come out.
But we had a fix.
You could wind --
[ Inaudible ]
All right, we need a volunteer
because we might need
this tape again.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
Wow.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: So
the things that we used
when we were researching,
because we had
to research our childhoods
a little bit,
and when you research your
childhood, you come across props
and they become sort of
the backdrop of the story.
But the main parts of our story,
the things that were most important
are things that kind of exist all
of the time through all of the ages.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Friendship.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: And family.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
Conquering your fears.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg:
And awkwardness,
like if your hair gets really
frizzy because it's raining.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: [Inaudible]
awkwardness is a common theme
throughout the ages that
not every 10-year-old
in ancient Rome had his [inaudible]
securely fastened leading
to awkward moments, but we wanted
to share an awkward
moment from our book.
So at this point, have you
ever accidentally hit somebody?
Like you were kind of
waving stuff around,
and you accidentally
bonked somebody,
and you're like, "Oh, I'm sorry?"
So our main character is actually
accidentally bonked the girl he
really likes, and his sister,
Loren, is refusing to bail him out.
Here's another question
for the how to talk
to girls category of
Trivial Pursuit.
Say you just whacked Kelly
Ann Majors in the face
with what's supposed
to be a bag of poop.
Do you continue to pretend that
the bag is full of dog poop
and thereby forever
create in her mind a link
between you and dog poop?
Or cop to only pretending to pick up
dog poop and thereby forever create
in her mind a link between
you and fake dog poop?
I ended up doing something else
all together which was to trip
over Bow Bow's leash and fall
to the ground while saying
something suave like [inaudible].
Loren and Kelly Ann leaned over me.
Bow Bow wrapped the leash
around me one more time
and began licking my face.
Considering the last thing I
saw him doing with that tongue,
I was not too excited about this.
Are you okay, David?
Asked Kelly Ann.
I didn't mean to freak you out.
She adjusted her hat.
It was green, which make her
dark eyes more noticeable.
He's fine, said Loren,
less sympathetically.
She grabbed my hand
pulling me to my feet.
You're so weird.
The button girl, Kelly Ann said.
That's Loren, I said.
Kelly Ann pointed to my bag.
I don't want to ask, but is
that dog -- I quickly decided.
Fake dog poop was still
better than dog poop.
Poop. I held up the bag
and let out a big laugh
like the last thing
a person would have
in a bag while walking
a dog was poop.
No, no. It's pine cones.
Pine cones?
Kelly Ann shook her head.
What are you carrying
pine cones in a bag for?
Why indeed?
I looked at Loren who gave me
the you're on your own look.
Why am I carrying pine
cones in a plastic bag?
I said, stalling for time.
Yes. From the tone of her voice,
Kelly Ann was no longer worried
about my physical well-being.
It was my mental state
that was now in question.
I looked at the Mason's house
which was across the street
from grandma's house, and they
already started decorating
for Christmas, which
is something people do
around here on Thanksgiving day.
Don't ask me why.
For a wreath, I said.
A pine cone wreath.
A wreath? Yes.
Because we're Jewish said
Loren not so helpfully.
I gave her the evil eye
behind Kelly Ann's back.
Hanukkah wreath, I mumbled.
I'd never seen a Hanukkah wreath.
Probably because they didn't exist.
But it sounded like
something that could exist.
The Abrams put up yellow
and blue Christmas lights
and called them Hanukkah lights.
Wait, said Kelly.
I thought you were Chinese?
I'm both, I said.
You can be Chinese and
Buddhist or Chinese
and [inaudible] or
Chinese and Jewish.
I managed to stop laughing
before I paired being Chinese
with every religion on earth.
But there aren't too many
Chinese Jews around here, I added.
It almost felt like
a trivia question.
How many Chinese Jews
live in Virginia?
Answer, ha, ha, ha.
What are you talking about?
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: So
when we were both growing up,
we grew up in different
parts of the state,
and I was the only Jewish
kid in southwest Virginia.
I mean, there were
a couple of others.
There was Ezra Promutter [assumed
spelling], but it mostly felt
like me and Ezra Promutter.
And Wendy grew up in
northern Virginia with --
actually one of the few Chinese
American kids growing up.
So when we met, we sort of bonded
over the fact that we were only's.
And I mean, we were a
lot more than just Jewish
or just Chinese as everybody is.
We're all multiple things,
but when we did our reading
when we were kids, we were
trying to look for ourselves,
and I did find myself
in a wrinkle in time.
I saw myself in Meg or in
reading Harriet the Spy.
I saw myself in Harriet.
Wendy did too.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
All right.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: All right.
Awesome.
[ Inaudible ]
Cool. Well, this was the first book
that I looked in, and
I saw a Jewish kid.
And I thought, "Oh my gosh.
This book is just like me.
This girl is just like me."
Even though I had never owned
a pentafore, and I didn't live
in New York in the early 1900's.
But just the fact that
she was the same religion
of me made a huge difference.
So --
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: And for me,
that same book was
Blubber by Judy Bloom.
Now, the main character in
Blubber is not Chinese American,
but her best friend is.
And she has kind of a side role in
the story, but that meant the world
to me because I had never
seen in a book a portrayal
of a Chinese American girl
who lived in modern times.
And I think like subconsciously one
of my other books is called
The Great Wall of Lucy Wu,
and the main character's
name is Tracy Wu.
And I think I was trying to
subconsciously connect them.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg:
So when we were writing,
we talked about being only's.
And of course when we wrote
this book, we wrote it together.
So we weren't only's anymore.
And it's a lot less lonely.
If anybody had seen my office and
how messy it is, it would be nice
to get out of that office to
go write with somebody else.
So this is me at my bar
mitzvah because little bits
of our lives do show
up in this book.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: And this
is me when I was in high school
in the 80's, and I got the -- sorry.
I was trying to do what
they called the preppy style
so I had my sweater
over my shoulders.
And what I drew from that
for David was David likes
to do trivia contests, and
I did forensics contests.
And I did the connection -- as you
know, we like to try new things
and then get better at them, and
that's what David's trying to do.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: So the
day after was a television show.
It was a movie made
for TV that aired
in the 80's, and it was super scary.
It was about what life would be
like if a nuclear bomb went off,
and for us, another
thing that was different
about the 80's is there
was no Netflix and chill.
We did not have that
many TV channels
so everybody watched this show,
and it got us really scared.
And so that fear, and what we found
that every decade of people --
they're afraid of something
else and something different,
but we've all gotten
through all of those decades.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: And then
one thing we hope you take away is
that we can all be peacemakers
whether you start small at home
or you try to extend to something
beyond just your backyard.
We can all do stuff.
So we also wanted to talk
about some of the other factors
that went into the story.
So we have food we talked about.
We had dumplings and [inaudible].
We talked about going to
different language schools.
I went to Chinese school.
Madelyn's kids go to Hebrew school.
We talked about how we both had
this connection to Virginia.
So all those things kind
of play into the story
and then there's the
good old Trivial Pursuit.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: And also
friendship because the fact
that I think we were friends made a
really big difference in our ability
to be able to write
and to write together.
Do you want to talk about
that any [inaudible]?
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Well,
I have we have like one minute.
So does anybody have any questions?
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Madelyn Rosenberg:
How did we meet?
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Oh,
we met in writer's group.
We both belonged to the Society of
Children's Book -- Children's --
Society of Children's Book
Writers and Illustrators.
And I was invited to
join Madelyn's group.
Yeah.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: We did --
and because we were the same age
and we had kids the same age, we
kind of bonded over that and got
to know each other better.
And when we were writing this book,
we got to know each
other better better.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang:
Okay, question over here.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah.
I know. I know.
I kind of felt like I -- the book,
yeah, so after I wrote the --
he's talking about my book,
The Great Wall of Lucy Wu,
and I mentioned Yao Ming and
Pat Summit unfortunately.
Yeah, Pat Summit is gone.
[ Inaudible ]
That's right.
And Yao Ming retired.
I was like, "Oh my gosh.
I better not put anymore
professional athletes in my book."
>> Madelyn Rosenberg:
I think from now
on we can only mention fake people
in our books instead of real people.
Any other questions?
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Any
other questions or comments?
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: So
I'll ask Wendy a question.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Okay.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg:
What works better for you?
Writing alone or writing together?
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Oh.
Well, I like both.
I think I like having both actually
because writing along is super
lonely, and what I love writing
with you is when I
got tired of writing,
I'd be like ping, here
Madelyn catch.
What about you?
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: Great.
One question a lot of people ask
us is how did you write together?
Right? Because sometimes you're
trying to decide what movie
to go see or you're trying to decide
what restaurant to go to for dinner,
you argue with the other person.
Right? So how do you
argue over 250 pages?
But it actually worked
really well for us.
Basically, we took turns.
You got to talk really, really
loud because we can't hear you.
You got to come all the
way up here and talk to us.
We can't hear.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Oh,
our favorite children's books.
Oh wow. One of my -- one
of the books I come back
to is a series called The Great
Brain, and it's about a boy growing
up in Utah in the 19th century,
and their lives were
so different from ours.
And he had a horse,
and I love horses.
So super jealous.
>> Madelyn Rosenberg: Mine
was The Phantom Told This
because it was really
one of the first books
that taught me how fun it
could be to play with words,
and I'm reading the sign that
says wrap it up so thank you.
We're going to wrap it up.
Thank you guys so so
much for listening.
>> Wendy Wan-Long Shang: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.